you know when you walk into an
environment how would you know where to
set up the interview how close to frame
the camera things like that what would
you be going through
well I generally work with the
cinematographer and we discuss you know
the the basics that you want in an
interview where you want some depth of
field you don't want anybody sitting up
against a flat wall and you know we know
the basics of what it takes to make a
shot look good and we just work around
it and tweak around it and pick an angle
and if it didn't work we pick something
else it's a creative moment and you know
you just get into it I I don't have
preconceived ideas I come into the
environment and discuss with my
cameraman and say you know what do we
have what are our options most of the
time when your environment in an
environment that is not a shooting
environment you're dealing with the the
limitations and so it's working within
those limitations to try to find the
best shot the best angle what are some
of the things you're doing to put your
subject well I never do an interview
that I haven't had a correspondence in
advance I've always talked to the person
either in person or on the telephone I
always have a really deep knowledge of
them of their career of their history of
where they fit into this story of what
their interview what I need their
interview to do because you're always
carrying the story in your head and in
your heart you you and you emotionally
are attached to the idea that you're
trying to present and you are looking
for subjects to flesh out that idea you
know the idea that you go out there and
you just shoot a bunch of stuff and then
you go into the cutting room and cut it
is a little naive because you have to
and somewhere in your psyche a story
that you want to tell and you have to
know how the people that you're
interviewing fit into the telling of
that story so that's that's what you
come to the interview with then when you
sit with the person that you're
interviewing you've already established
some rapport with them either by direct
conversation or on the telephone and
they have a sense of where you're going
with the interview it's very important
that they be comfortable with where
you're going that you're not going to go
in and ask them some personal salacious
question that is going to shut them off
because if you get into areas where
people are shocked or surprised at what
you say I mean that's not the kind of
filmmaker I am some people like to do
that they like to shock and surprise
their subjects but I find that if you're
trying to tell your story that turns
people off so I tried to take them into
areas where they will fulfill the needs
of the story and then I just let them
talk just like you do
you